all right I'm Justin this is Tom we're
here with some breaking news oh well
it's not I guess it's not really
breaking we so Nintendo has been on kind
of a down slide but we've known this is
coming been coming for a while but
Nintendo finally admitted it like
basically they've come out and and
changed their sales projections earlier
this year they said we're gonna sell
nine million we use through the end of
2014 and they've changed that to 2.8 2.8
and they've their stock has taken a
nosedive their projections for making a
profit throughout the year they were
gonna originally do a pretty sizable
profit and now they're gonna lose 240
million dollars and that's like that's
what they're projecting so could even be
worse than that may be better so you're
not not all together a great news story
but we did just come off of some NPD
numbers where the pds was the
top-selling console for both December
and all of 2013 it's like a lot of
people are just calling this complete
doom and gloom that Nintendo should just
fold under that they should be a Sega
and that they should start selling off
their properties willy-nilly but that I
think that's absolutely ridiculous I
mean the 3ds is still the top selling
console evita the 360 the ps3 the xbox
one and the ps4 yes the three vs sold
well that it it didn't have real
competition outside of the vita in the
wii u basically as far as a pole system
in a prime for a year i'm usually okay
so when we talk about nintendo doom and
gloom gloom which has been since 96
roughly I'm always on the side of what
no to I mean to be fair we was getting
but we were good yet Elizabeth um
financially financial I'm always on the
side of you guys are nuts it's gonna be
fine its Nintendo right now it's kind of
a different scenario because I don't
really know how they make a gain ground
in the console space I think they've
just been completely confusing the
marketplace as far as like what the wii
u is well they don't have games is the
problem it's cuz in hendo since 96 has
been we're gonna do this alone and i
guess we'll have one or two third
parties that's that's been their mo
since the n64 well and it was going to
change the wii u was gonna have all
these great third-party titles and then
then that kind of backed off i know and
and it's like nintendo makes great games
so every few months you get something
like mario which is incredible
and that can't really compete with like
the ps4 which has all the indie games
and has the first party studios or the
third party support but I don't think
you can count them out because no matter
what i am going to buy a nintendo system
for nintendo games and that's what I
expect out of it and I really don't need
to like I don't feel like they need to
go to playstation or sag or even pc to
try and sell those experiences because
their best when they make their own
control that supports that how do you
think they can turn around the fortunes
of the council space then i decided i
don't see a scenario that they can i
really at this point you have to come
out with a new console or or having a
wii u that gets rid of that tethered
gamepad which is really raising the
price of it i think if they put out a
cheap wii u it like maybe two hundred
dollars a hundred fifty dollars without
a wii u gamepad that that can make a big
difference i know but it doesn't also
hurt that they have negative momentum
right now that there is any kind of buzz
is almost a negative votes so even
lowering the price like Sony do with the
Vita doesn't spur sales because people
have a negative association with it well
one thing the antenna has talked about
doing Satoru Iwata who's not going to
resign who said that there's not much
change up in the upper management he
said that they do need to folks that
they're doing and one of those things is
is looking at smartphones now I don't
think that the best way to do that is
just to port over the experiences that
they already have on a smart that is the
worst way to do it exactly but Nintendo
is really smart about using technology
and about using like what other people
are doing like using the Wii U and
creating really interesting experiences
and creating something brand-new
something you wouldn't have expected
before and I'd love to see what they can
do on mobile I actually think they need
to make original mobile games with their
characters that you know like with link
and Mario because then you have the
association with people especially kids
who know Angry Birds now like Mario is
cool I like Mario and then they can
graduate to like the real Mario games
and the real Zelda games but I think
that's intended nice to do to kind of
get a foothold and a younger audience
that's losing interest in them yeah and
I mean this is definitely bad news all
around for Nintendo their stock is
taking a bad news for everyone it's not
just in 10 degrees we need them in the
space they are like a games company
first performance you know I think they
have there's a lot of things that
they're gonna be able to do going into
this new year but to keep up on all of
your Nintendo news and all of your
gaming news in general
sure to tune in to gamespot follow us on
twitter follow us on Facebook you know
how those things work and thanks for
watching